well yesterday we started the show with
this disastrous news out of Italy in
which a far-right nationalist group with
individuals within it like Georgia
Maloney who have neo-fascist roots and
origins in their sort of political lives
are coming to power in Italy and we also
talked a little more broadly about the
origins and the catalysts for this
rightward shift in Italy it shouldn't
surprise us that in the 24 hours
following the news of what's taking
place in Italy American right Wingers
who of course don't claim to be fascists
or neo-fascists or anything of the sort
have rallied behind Georgia Maloney in
some cases without even actually knowing
what her name is Marjorie Taylor green
referring to her as George Joe maybe she
thinks it's a man I don't really know
but we'll get to that in a moment and
saying that this is a great thing that
there is the rise of the right in Europe
which is not altogether wrong in fact we
talked about that yesterday but also
pretending as though Georgia Maloney and
her party are just kind of mainstream
individuals rather than the extreme
rightists that they are so let's take a
look at a couple of Clips first here is
Charlie Kirk on the Charlie Kirk show
saying this isn't fascism Georgia
Maloney and her ideology this is middle
of the road common sense
um take a listen
here of course on the American Media is
Georgia Maloney being called a fascist
on MSNBC you know they're all for
democracy until somebody who they don't
like wins and then they call well
there's there's two different things
here right you can be a fascist who won
through Democratic means now she's not
literally a fascist but she was a member
when she was younger of the youth front
that's a neo-fascist it's the youth wing
of a neo-fascist political party called
the Italian social movement it's it's
not a question of opinion it's what it
is that person Mussolini play Cut 35.
the the victory of a party that has its
roots in Italian fascism yeah plain and
simple uh the the brothers of Italy it's
called Georgia Milani's party uh is
concerning to everybody uh it
accompanies as you said this move in
Europe who could think that in Sweden a
party with right wing neo-fascist Roots
would now be dominant in in Parliament
it's sweeping all across Europe and they
can't figure out why
it's not fascist it's common sense it's
normal it's middle of the road
it's about things
that are
eternally important
not about gender Theory post-modernist
constructs
squashing the imperialist colonialist
history no no this is about things that
transcend all of that and this is a
perfect example of exactly how these
parties become popular we talked about
this yesterday we we talked about
exactly this this is what they do this
is the type of stuff that they say oh
these are about the real issues you've
got to be afraid of immigrants from
other countries we've got to stop the
gender stuff by saying that this is
normal he is proving exactly the point
we made yesterday
the American political scene is going
through the exact same thing now if you
see
the globalists ah the globalists
the globalists there it is the uniparty
they have to do everything they possibly
can
to try and
thwart this movement now we're going to
get back to that in a moment but it was
not just Charlie Kirk Marjorie Taylor
Greene tweeting congratulations to
Giorgio Maloney and to the people of
Italy of course just another one of
Marjory Taylor Green's typos as usual
and radical and repugnant Republican
congresswoman Lauren bobert
tweeted quote this month Sweden voted
for a right-wing government now Italy
voted for a strong right-wing government
she has to acknowledge that in Italy
it's even further right but she can't
use the term neo-fascist the entire
world is beginning to understand that
the woke left does nothing but destroy
November 8 is coming soon and the USA
will fix our house and Senate Let
Freedom Reign this is a hard right
ideology that dabbles into neo-fascism
now in the last 24 hours there have been
many enlightened centrists and others
who have come out of the woodwork and
said it's not really fascism Georgia
Maloney it's it's the brothers of Italy
it's not really fascism
no but it has its origins in fascism
Maloney joined the youth front which is
the youth wing of the neo-fascist
political party the Italian social
movement MSI in 1992. they've taken
these extreme nationalist positions hard
line against immigration put out the
Italian Navy to patrol the water and
block migrants from arriving by sea Vox
has written that Maloney's Victory will
roll back minority rights including the
rights of women lgbtq people and
migrants it's the typical hard right
package the brothers of Italy use the
Insignia and the slogan God country
family which is an echo to its fascist
predecessors she's against abortion
she's against same-sex marriage she's
against same-sex parenting she's against
multiculturalism in May of 2020 she
praised Giorgio almirante who's the
co-founder of the Italian social
movement which is that group that uh
neo-fascist group I told you about
um almirando was a Nazi collaborator and
editor-in-chief of an anti-semitic and
racist magazine which published
something called the manifesto of race
there's a lot of this stuff
melonious praised the Italian dictator
Mussolini as a quote good politician the
best of the last 50 years that was in a
French newscast in 1996. so this stuff
is not just being made up out of thin
air this is the reality and what's
happening is a sort of rewriting of
History some people don't really know
that much about Italian fascism others
are easily convinced that this is
nothing to do with it but the roots of
this movement are Italian fascism that's
the reality and so certainly you can
make the case she is not a fascist per
se and I'm with you but this is a hard
right group with its origins in terms of
the individuals that make it up in
neo-fascism and even worse and it
shouldn't shock us even for a second
that the right Wingers are jumping to
defend it because they've openly openly
um
romanticized these types of movements
during the Trump era the science tells
us that one of the best ways to get
consistent deep sleep is lowering your
core body temperature when your body
stays cooler at night you're more
comfortable and your sleep is better our
sponsor sleep me is the home of chili
sleep the customizable climate
controlled sleep solutions that can
improve your sleep by keeping you cooler
at night there are three different chili
sleep systems there's the uler the cube
and the new Doc Pro with double the
cooling power all three systems are
water-based temperature controlled
mattress toppers that fit over your
existing mattress to provide you with
your ideal sleep temperature you can go
as cool as 55 degrees you can go really
hot if you want I keep mine at 60
beautiful 10 temperature for me don't
wake up hot and sweaty chilly sleep
keeps me asleep all night it feels great
I didn't know it was possible to love
sleeping even more than I already did go
to sleep.me slash Pacman to learn more
and get 25 off your new chili Sleep
System click the link below to start
staying cool at night